Les chevaliers jamais fléchis n'ont jamais faibli les explorateurs
...happened about 600 years ago.
It was the biggest fleet of boats the world had seen. They were from a great sea power.
Yeah, but who were they? From where had they come?
For till Acre was still a wilderness.
It's all just a big joke. I mean, there weren't any big ships until, uh, until geese!
No, the Spanish!
Of course I'm alright.
Captain, I know that city.
Keep well clear of the coast. There are reefs.
Drop anchor and lower our lifeboats.
I saw such big ships! Big as a house! Enormous! Enormous!
So many ships, and such large ones!
You'll see it, come on!
Oh yeah, come on!
What do they want here?
Chinese, I should have thought of them!
The Chinese, the Chinese, and why isn't always them?
Their history has gone on for a long time, 10,000 years at least.
9,000 years before our era, the Chinese reached Taiwan, then the Philippines, and Malaysia, and finally the Fiji Islands.
Some say they crossed the Pacific Ocean, arriving in South America from the east long before Christopher Columbus.
But their brilliant maritime adventure really began with an important invention: the compass.
It's a very special metal. It always points to the north that can be useful on a ship.
The captain would know his course at night or in a fog in any weather.
At the end of the 13th century, the Venetian explorer Marco Polo even then admired some of the excellent ships of the Chinese fleet.
fleet truly extraordinary enormous ships 60 caverns and a crew of 300 men nobody has ever seen
anything like it the emperor chu zi has just acceded to the throne and promptly eliminated
his enemies retained only a selection of his advisors who have dominated the mongols and
eliminated all our enemies and enlarged the middle kingdom now your majesty it is time to explore the
world around us your empire deserves the riches of the world the sea can carry us to unknown lands
But we must have ships.
We will consider what you say, Chang'e.
You have always been an obedient servant wise in what you say.
See, the Middle Kingdom's at your feet.
Your feet.
The riches of our empire found in the land.
The land.
Confucius has said, "He who plows the fields brings prosperity and happiness to China.
From exploration, no great good will come."
What? Confucius said all that?
Well, some say so, he said, sir.
We will consider your words.
Sir.
So, our honorable and revered First Wife, it is a pleasure to see a wife you come.
A word to put in your ear, Lord and Master.
Hmm?
It is in our interest to protect China from foreign influence.
It is what Confucius says, my lord.
And have you read Confucius?
I have heard talk of him.
Oh, venerated First Wife, I shall meditate on it.
You may go.
To our most recent wife, will you not sit down?
Right here.
Well, now, my little lotus flower, what's on your mind?
- Go on. - My lord and master,
I only believe, I mean, well, you have heard that there are wondrous marvels everywhere in the world.
It would surely enhance your glory.
- Oh, is it your pleasure to have them? - Oh, yeah.
Majestie.
Chang-Hai, you will create our Imperial Navy, the biggest one in the world,
and I hereby appoint you commander.
And you will explore the whole world.
There are reports of animals that are strange. There are even black men, they say.
The Chinese set to work inventing the dry dock.
This let them lift even the largest ships out of the water for inspection and repair.
The whole hull, and replace the planks that are rotten.
Understand? Then put on a new coat of paint.
Yes, Admiral.
Water top.
Another Chinese invention, watertight compartments, so that slight damage to the hull doesn't sink the ship.
Sail across whole oceans.
They will go into foreign lands.
It's against the words of Confucius.
I have an idea.
There's nobody around.
I can't.
Confucius, they did this!
And the locks are guarded night and day.
Despite the objections of the followers of Confucius, the Emperor had indeed
a fleet that the world had ever seen.
1,600 ships and big ships to carry a great treasure,
each with nine masts and crews of 600 men.
Junks with three and four masts that are easier to maneuver.
War ships with oars and a reinforced bow for ramming.
And some with gunpowder to blow up enemy ships.
Hawkins of the sea with flat bottoms.
And there are some that are secret.
No, be quiet!
The secret.
It is our most precious guide, our fate depends on it.
Ooh.
Of course for the Straits of Sumatra.
For the Sumatra.
I'm full of pirates.
Chezui and his Malaysian pirates plunder ships in the Straits of Malacca.
I'm going to take in the warships first.
You keep fleet back.
Warships are going on reconnaissance.
We can get that treasure.
Yeah, sure, Chief. Yeah, by the way, that hurt, Chief.
Put that lantern out if you want him to spot us or what? Hey!
No arse, isn't there?
Chief, the lousy pirates is arse.
No, no.
It's Chief. We ain't gonna build their kind of ship.
- Same as theirs.
- Yeah, welcome to the island of Buddha's birthplace.
You drank the sacred water, so now you can enter the temple.
Be your guy.
- Your welcomes the distinguished guests of the Middle Kingdom.
He says that a bandit has taken control of the neighboring city of Kutte.
He asks if you will help us get rid of him so that we may live in peace.
- Say we'll try to get rid of him.
- Go with you on one of your ships, sir?
- Yes, of course, you will be our interpreter.
- As big as the captains, I'm going to be a captain when I grow up.
- And you?
- Me?
- Wanna be?
...is an elephant driver.
Demanding the Imperial of the Middle Kingdom?
Captain Hong Bao salute you, sir.
They bring many gifts for you.
What'd he say?
He says you are a miserable crawling worm,
ready to squirm under his foot.
Hmm, your emperor is a filthy bug that he will squash under his thumb.
He has no intention of listening to your stupid gibberish.
He is going to take all the treasure you have in your ships
and deal with you as Elish.
He said all that?
Yeah, well, you tell that stuff, Cigar Nose.
That pompous fleabag, that puffed-up ragdoll, that slimy snake, that flimby fish-face, you tell him that-
We will give great consideration to his majesty's very generous proposition.
We'll give serious consideration to bashing his brains in?
Shh! What?
Sure, Alex Payne.
What? The poor entrance! His whole army is there!
Too many of them.
Yes, but if his whole army is there, it means there can't be any here.
Hey, you're right.
Now's the time.
Hmm.
Hey, ho!
Guy alone.
Just miserable worms and filthy insects that you'll crush under your thumb.
There's some insects sting!
What?
Interpreter, I want you to be very sure His Majesty understands us.
He will bring all his troops back here at once, otherwise...
Who is in charge here?
It is I, and what is it you're having to offer?
Come and see, our ships are here.
Yes, indeed.
You're having how many?
Well, let's count 'em.
Plates, 100 saucers, and as many cups, 100 dishes, and 20 tea pots, that is the total of all.
Agree!
Now will you take me back home, huh?
We're going to go to Arabia, our next stop, see--
Arabia? I don't want to go to Arabia!
This is Arabia.
Nobody's too sure.
Apparently it's that way, towards the setting sun.
Fine, fine, but why take me?
It's a magic animal that brings good luck closer.
Ask him what exactly is this animal, and is it for sale?
Hang on!
If you promise to be a good king, and you're not going to know your neighbors, then you can run alone home.
It's time to take the long journey home.
See, the thing is, the weirdest-
I know, I know, we're the dirty pirates, your majesty.
To present a Killian, a legendary animal that always brings happiness.
Oh, he's so cute. I want one. I want him.
Oh.
No!
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
At the end of the 15th century, China was the greatest maritime power.
The emperor had a new capital built in Beijing, later Peking, in the north of the country.
And in the center of Beijing, a forbidden city, many palaces of a thousand rooms each, a million workers used to complete it.
Expeditions went on, and our travelers brought back all sorts of exotic animals from around the world.
Oh, he splendid, that heavenly horse.
And the killing, it said the Greenlock.
Look at that monster, terribly ugly.
Look at that horse with stripes, that's ridiculous.
And that big bird can't even fly.
Is any animal more awkward?
Such a bird shouldn't exist!
It's-
...opening up to Adventures of the Sea.
Meanwhile, back in Beijing...
No, my master, it's right here. We're in China's own borders that our ancient faith would be strengthened.
All these expeditions, these type of animal animals, they're useless, Majesty.
No, I mean, yes, Your Majesty, that's true. I have seen signs in the sky.
If we don't stop all these expeditions, then great calamity will befall us, sire.
Beware. If you are mistaken, I'll punish you.
You and your signs in the sky, you have to say it. You have to say it.
If the catastrophe you predicted doesn't happen to China, then what will happen to us?
Don't worry, it will happen.
As always, blocking progress is quite a powerful force.
People are easily frightened off.
The Chinese stopped all voyages of discovery under penalty of death.
China withdrew behind a great wall, and it was the end of an extraordinary adventure.
Just think, the Chinese had sailed over so much of the Earth's ocean
when Henry the Navigator hadn't even reached the equator.
And Captain Bojar, you recall that?
What if the Chinese had continued sailing?
And what if they'd met up?
Imagine for a moment what if the Chinese junks of the Middle Kingdom
had met the Portuguese caravels.
What a turn in history that might have taken, defies imagination.
And what happened to our Chinese friends?
Oh, who can say?
Zheng He probably died at sea in a storm.
As for Hongbao, I sure did, my boy, and some much bigger than that.
The big Chinese junk, red sails, but that was long ago.
In our own time, just off Kenya, there's an island called Pat, where distinctive people live.
A mixture of Africans and Chinese, it's true.